wann immer das fluc wanne leben häufig
daraus heute mal wieder recht herzlich
willkommen bereits in seiner neuen der
besonnen reagiert auf die holzschuhe
ende meiner letzten tour hätten reaction
waren wir kurz vor dem neuen workshops
stehen geblieben der ohne worte heißt
und ich würze haben das schauen wir doch
mal ihre treiben drei männer mit der
inhaltlichen gestaltung des workshops
beschäftigt war haben die produzenten
die teams zusammen gewürfelt
wir haben kells mit francesca in einem
team
ich wär' doch frei gewählt ich freue
mich ich bin ab und planer ist auf
meiner seite
mit harry und hayley verstehen sich
überhaupt nicht deswegen wird das
besonders interessant was ist unsere
chance freunde zu werden
danke
damit aber honda sollte meiner ansicht
nach eigentlich das ganze mit schauraum
machen weil die beiden die passen
zusammen wie die faust aufs auge haben
sagt beleidigtes passt zusammen wie die
faust aufs auge das war gar keinen sinn
ich bin froh dass david mein partner ist
immer voll dabei
der neiße preis
preis ist sogar der scheiß nein du bist
mein baby stirbt doch die macht soll die
geschichte dreier was
das
irgendwie sind gute teams aber irgendwie
auch extrem komisch also ich bin
gespannt auf den workshop und wir
überhaupt funktionieren wir unsere erste
aufgabe ist es die nonverbalen signale
ihres partners zu lesen bitte um abend
eure partner und drückt die emotion aus
die ihr vor euch seht
das
die sollen jetzt exzellent ausdrücken
ich bin happy ich bin aufgeregt keine
ahnung ich finde für manche wörter die
es im englischen gibt gibt es auf
deutsch gar keine richtigen begriff
versteht wie ich meinen namen bis der
international
mit t shirt aus besten mercure in ganz
deutschland geschaffen
[Musik]
die freuen sich da jetzt und drücken
damit die emotionen aus inwiefern ist
das jetzt ja das ist nun verbale
kommunikation so aber hey inwiefern
bringt es die denn weiter nicht auf die
um haben sich die ganze zeit
die sind ja schon fertig wusste ich mich
wollt auch gar nicht gerade irgendwie
eifersüchtig machen
das war eine tolle umarmung es war als
hätte sie mich lange nicht gesehen
ok
die sache ist dass er wie heißt der typ
noch mal ja hier ist auf jeden fall
eigentlich ganz gut mit charlotte
freunde die sache ist allerdings dass
man da ja was mit vorrang haben will
schon eigentlich auch mit rollatoren
hatte allerdings so komische beziehung
mit seiner ex freundin will deswegen
gerade nichts von honda weil er sich
noch nicht so öffnen kann und jetzt ist
sein bester romy zusammen mit ron an
diesem workshop versteht glaube ich nur
noch bahnhof ich auch von einer schon
weiter scheint als fern er sich da
wieder ein liebesdreieck zwischen david
und jetzt was müssen wir jetzt etwas
aufschreiben
wenn das sein soll da musst du deine
rechtschreibung nochmal überdenken aber
die jungs müssen jetzt quasi
aufschreiben was sie dachten was die
mädels ihnen zeigen wollten
deutsch gelernt bei jutta ich habe
bestimmt dass man das richtig 665
nebenbei dieser typ sa-2 uni abschlüsse
und offensichtlich ein höher
zwei uni abschlüsse wie kann es sein
dass ich bin nicht ich hab den namen
schon vergessen michael harry denkt sich
auch so
herr ich fühle mit dir löst es die
gleichen emotionen aus wenn franchise
kader kerl zum abend punkt das macht
mich wütend dass in diesem schmalen
umarmung sondern nonverbale
kommunikationsmittel
vor allem finde ich es lustig dass harry
eine andere person schmal hier nennt
rabbi francesca und ich sind uns
definitiv näher gekommen
gemacht lerne hier habt ihr habt aber
keinen punkt bekommen
die frage ist jetzt gibt es gleich auch
noch mal umgekehrt also dass die jungs
irgendwie was zum ausdruck bringen
müssen wir das wäre interessant im
zweiten teil des workshops seht ihr euch
tief in die seele dieses ritual
ermuntert die single sich auf einen
emotionalen ebene zu begegnen
sind wir uns jetzt auf einer tieferen
emotionalen ebene begegnete ich glaube
es nicht interessant und die ja bereits
super augenkontakt geschätzt nicht
gedacht aber man kann leuten in die
seele streik geht zurück in ein
ladengeschäft interessant was da abgeht
auch er hier der namenlose mit ronda
schauen sich die ganze zeit an ich
checks nicht
cook sich einfach an
jackies
wir können uns gerne noch länger
aber ich sehe jetzt keinen sinn drin
musste er weinen
er hat wirklich warum weinst du pro
ihr habt euch einfach in die augen
extrem skurril folge heute ich habe all
die dinge gesehen die sich ausmachen ist
einfühlsam liebevoll herzlich
rücksichtsvoll und natürlich schöner du
bist einfach jedes adjektiv das es gibt
und das habe ich jetzt erkannt dadurch
dass ich dir einfach fünf sekunden die
augen geschaut hab sehr gut nike ihr
seid so lange könnte gerade drei kann
beziehungen führen
warum ging es doch darum ging es doch
nike
dieser workshop hat mich erkennen lassen
sich jetzt in meine lage sich denn ich
mag sehr gute rollen als auch da wird
wirklich gern day welt seine
auslandsreisen workshop hat mir die
augen gehören gar nicht bewusst wie sehr
ich mag da besteht wohl doch eine
tiefere verbindung ist vermutet er ab du
hast erstmal sehr schöner
gesichtsausdruck hier gerade hat ja eine
abfuhr erteilt und hat ihren korb
gegeben und gesagt ich kann es gar nicht
ich brauche meine zeit bruder wenn nun
im edel doch sagst braucht seine zeit
kannst du doch nicht einen tag später
ankommen nur weil sie dann anderen typen
hat so von wegen ach so ich bin übrigens
dann doch eher was sie zu sagen
achtung ich stecke in der zwickmühle ich
habe ja schon und honda waren zuerst da
kann er doch jetzt nicht einfach
reinspringen
also ich kann alle seiten verstehen
kannst ganz ganz ganz ganz verzwickt die
mühle die hälfte der zeit im resort ist
um größer hat leider ihre gäste bestraft
wenn sie und ich waren köln doch jetzt
bringt sie belohnung ins spiel
also da ist eine kiste warte mal ganz
kurz
aber jetzt kriegen wir die namen kriegen
ab jetzt eine belohnung wo sie
eigentlich eine bestrafung bisher
verdient hätten oder gibt es weiterhin
bestrafungen und belohnungen kommen und
ob dazu werden die situation aus dem weg
gehen
es bleibt spannend
das ein geschenk wie weihnachten
ja
exakt wie weihnachten kriegst du neue
glühbirne für deine lampe glory harry
bitte öffne meine kiste
sind das apple watches für jede person
das sind so kleine touren die iraner die
uhr schwarz ist gelten resort regeln ok
oh mein gott ich weiß nicht ob ich da
jetzt vielleicht schon bisher zu weit
denke aber heißt es jetzt quasi wenn die
uhr schwarz ist also wie lagarde gesagt
habe dann gelten die im resort regeln
von wegen jahren mit niemanden umarmen
küssen rummachen whatever aber wenn
beispielsweise das ding grün leuchtet
darf man regeln brechen drei
alterklassen hier und ich hätte jetzt
direkt machen was sie wollen oder wie
das halte ich für ein gerücht wenn zwei
menschen eine echte verbindung aufgebaut
haben personen die für begrenzte zeit
grünes licht das ändert jetzt natürlich
alles das heißt sie bekommen wirklich
den freifahrtschein allerdings nur für
bestimmte situationen also es ist jetzt
nicht so dass die sagen hey immer von
der und der usa teilnehmen und dem tag
dürfte etwas miteinander haben sondern
dass konzentriert sich wirklich auf die
beziehung genau zwischen zwei personen
und lana sagten okay ihr beiden bekommt
jetzt grünes licht ihr habt euch besser
kennengelernt jetzt wisst ihr was
starten
alter schwede okay es wird extrem
interessant noch in dieser sendung
allerdings wirklich an der zeit meine
heutige reaktion auf tour die hände
jetzt auch beenden meine lieben freunde
wenn es euch gefallen hat und dem bock
auf einen nächsten teilen drei tagen hat
dann gibt dem video einen daumen hoch
schaffen wir 50.000 like
weiterhin zeigen hey ihr seid weiterhin
interessiert daran diese serie weiter
zuschauen folgten auf instagram der ist
der laser luca vielleicht mag ich ja
immer noch mal drei millionen abonnenten
und kann deswegen francesca noch besser
an schreiben dass wir dann holzmöbel und
jetzt befinden wir uns auch schon im
auto meine lieben freunde wenn sie noch
kein abonnent von meinem kanal seit er
klickt hier oben gerne auf den zwei die
drauf sagt ich verpasse nämlich keine
videos mehr als das kostenlose und ihr
seid immer direkt als erstes mit dabei
wenn ich mir neue episode two händel
hochladen und hier ist ein weiteres
video verlinkt was ich eben auf einem
zweig kanal hochgeladen habe da ich sage
nicht was passiert also klickt einfach
drauf